- If I was in a coma and I smelled this
I'd probably wake up saying,
yeah, I want (laughs)
Whatever of this this is.
(energetic banjo music)
- Judging by the name "Moonshine"
I think it's going to be a nice, gentle--
- It's gonna be little stars in your head.
- I'm trusting you with this.
- Think of it as like, the
American version of Santra
Barely legal and is very potent.
- I just hope I don't
wake up below the ceiling
- I've been told my capacity
is good, so we shall see.
(energetic banjo music)
- Smells exciting.
- That smells like
petrol, I'm not kidding.
- Looks quite yummy.
- (squeals)
(tap-tap-tap-tap-tap)
- It's singing my mouth.
- It doesn't taste
anything like a cranberry.
- That was a mini-explosion in my mouth.
- It's incredibly hard
for me to believe that
this is going to get me high and yet,
as I say this--
- [Woman] I feel it
- This here is some apple pie moonshine
- It's gonna smell like
"oh I'm not harmful
"I'm, like, totally fine"
and then you're gonna have it
and it's gonna be like (gasps).
- It looks like diluted whiskey
- It's like a warm feeling
spreading through my body.
- I could have this instead
of my morning coffee
- It just feels like
it's hugging you, like--
- Malty swill and now it's like . . .
- If I go to a bar with
this and an open credit card
- That's it, that's the end of my life
- And I'm going to emerge the next day
like on the streets a poor man.
- It says "Shine Responsibly"
on the back of the bottle.
Shine responsibly you crazy diamond.
- It's going to be horrible.
- For all the exes I'm going
to text after this, I'm sorry.
(banjo music)
(coughs)
- That's like, really cheap,
the cheapest of cheap vodkas.
- The moment I took a sip,
I just, it just hit me.
- I can smell regret.
- [woman] (laughs)
- You know that scene in
Harry Potter when Dumbledore
had to drink that potion and he was dying?
- [Woman] (laughs)
- [Man] This is what he drank.
Catdaddy (laughs), catdaddy
- Which I guess is a great name if you are
into cats and daddy issues.
- It's mad sweet.
- [Man] Smells very sweet.
- (coughs)
- It's been a very bad
day this is making it
amazing right now.
- This is like a desert
- It was curry with masala
- It was like Sunscary alcohol.
- I would really like to
have this with a close friend
of mine, maybe on Valentine's Day.
- I can do like, multiple
shots of this shit
- [Woman] Yeah
- [Man] Every day.
- If I have to review this
like a master chef, I think
it's fruity, followed by
spicy, followed by alcohol-y.
- But it's like very Indian
- Yeah, very, very Indian
- [Man] Very Indian.
- This is a lot more
palatable compared to Indian--
- Tow santra
- I thought ilicit liquor
in the US would be like,
you know, um, bad, but it was good.
- It doesn't feel like it's
alcohol, you know what I mean?
- But I feel so good you know.
Like I just feel so good.
- I feel at peace.